It’s been an amazing 2017
for League of Legends,
with some great plays and even greater stories.
So in honor of some of the best
player storylines of the year,
we put together the Top 10.
But before we get into that, be sure to check out thescoreesportsbuilds.com
to help take your League skills to the next level.
And now for our list of the Top 10 best player storylines of the year.
Kicking off our list is the rookie superstar MikeYeung,
who helped North America win their Rift Rivals showdown against EU
and placed 10th with Phoenix1 in the summer split.
MikeYeung exploded onto the NA scene this summer,
with impressive performances on carry junglers that quickly earned him a fan following.
And despite that disappointing 10th place
finish,
MikeYeung earned Rookie of the Split for his stellar play,
and ended the year off
by signing with TSM for 2018.
[MikeYeung talking]
Though he is still relatively inexperienced,
MikeYeung will definitely be a player to watch heading into next year.
[Caster audio]
Uzi, who comes in at ninth on our list,
helped Royal Never Give Up win the Spring Split in the LPL,
come second in the summer and place
in the Top 4 at the world championship.
He is also China’s All-Star AD carry.
One of the LPL’s most veteran players,
Uzi was a key figure in China’s move toward all-Chinese rosters in 2017,
and RNG were one of its most successful examples.
[Caster audio]
Uzi is a part of China’s League of Legends
history.
And thanks to his play this year,
he is also a part of its future.
With more Chinese teams looking to follow
the examples of squads like Royal and OMG,
we’re excited to see where the region’s
domestic talent can go.
[Caster audio]
In eighth is IgNar who placed fourth with
Misfits in the Spring Split
and second in the summer.
He is also Europe’s All-Star support.
As a relatively new team, Misfits put up strong
results in 2017.
But besides making it to the summer final
against G2,
their story really got interesting at the World Championship.
[Caster audio]
Thanks in large part to IgNar’s innovative
support play on Leona and Blitzcrank,
the plucky Misfits took SKT to five games
and came within inches of knocking the defending champions out of the tournament.
[Caster audio]
It was further than anyone expected Misfits
to go.
And though SKT won in the end,
it was one of the most exciting series of the year.
[Daku talking]
Coming in at number seven,
Xmithie placed 5th-6th in the Spring Split with CLG,
second with Immortals in the Summer Split
and attended the World Championship.
Xmithie’s story in 2017 really comes down
to the summer split.
[Caster audio]
He came into an Immortals roster that struggled
to find its footing in the Spring Split,
placing 7th, and he changed everything.
After CLG and Immortals swapped junglers. Dardoch
and Xmithie,
all eyes were on a flashy, seemingly empowered, CLG roster.
But Xmithie smashed those expectations.
[Caster audio]
He flipped the script on an Immortals squad
the community had largely written off.
His stabilizing presence in the jungle was
a huge factor
in Immortals making it to the
summer finals in North America.
And although the team did not find much success at Worlds,
it probably wouldn’t have made it there at all without Xmithie.
[Caster audio]
Number six on our list is Europe’s veteran
AD carry, Rekkles.
Fnatic’s roster of relatively untested players
put up surprisingly consistent results in the EU LCS this year,
placing third in both splits.
And thanks to his performance this summer,
Rekkles was named the MVP.
But it was at Worlds that Rekkles led the
team to its most surprising result.
[Caster audio]
After an 0-3 start to the group stage,
Fnatic made it further than anyone could have expected.
[Caster audio]
But after being handed a rough defeat by Royal
Never Give Up in the quarterfinals,
Rekkles was devastated.
He’d taken his team further than anyone
expected,
but it wasn’t enough to make a deeper run at Worlds.
That said, Rekkles has re-signed with Fnatic
for three more years,
and we’re excited to see what he can do in 2018.
[Caster audio]
Number five on our list is Doublelift.
Doublelift’s 2017 started with a lull
as the veteran AD carry took a step back from the scene
after a grueling end to 2016.
But his passion for the competitive scene
drove him back to the Rift sooner than expected.
Doublelift subbed in for Team
Liquid to help that team salvage a tough Spring Split.
[Caster audio]
He returned to TSM for the summer and helped
the team win another domestic title,
though they went on to struggle at Worlds.
But the ending to his year might be the most
significant,
with Doublelift returning to Team Liquid in earnest
ahead of the 2018 Spring Split.
We're excited to see what seems like a friendly rivalry bloom.
[Doublelift talking]
Number four on our list is Crown,
who placed third in the Spring Split and fourth in the summer.
But Crown’s biggest achievement of the year,
his win at the 2017 World Championship,
came after a year of personal struggles for the mid laner.
Crown might not have been the strongest mid
laner in Korea this year,
but along with his teammates on Samsung,
he overcame personal adversity and brought it all together when it mattered most.
Crown’s story is proof that persistence
and hard work can take you all the way.
[Caster audio]
Number three on our list,
Bdd became the starting mid laner
on a Longzhu roster that had a terrible Spring Split.
But with the help of their summer roster,
Longzhu brought it back to win the split.
[Caster audio]
And though that had a lot to do with Pray
and Gorilla’s leadership,
Bdd was a huge factor in their summer run,
going toe-to-toe with the likes of Faker,
and finally living up to his enormous potential.
Coming in at number two is Ambition,
who was also part of Samsung’s third place Spring Split
and fourth place summer rosters.
But at Worlds, Ambition led his team to the
Summoner’s Cup,
with a huge 3-0 win over SKT in the finals.
[Caster audio]
But for Ambition, the win was a story four
years in the making.
[Caster audio]
After what seems like a lifetime in esports,
Ambition finally got his revenge on Faker.
And what better way to do it than on League’s
biggest stage?
And finally, at number one,
who else could it be but Faker?
Faker’s 2017 started off strong
with another domestic title
and a win at the Mid-Season Invitational,
but in the back half of the year,
the world’s most successful player
and most successful team stumbled.
[Caster audio]
Faker’s phenomenal play in 2017 cemented
him as the best player in the world.
[Caster audio]
But it was his defeat at the end of the year that
showed us a new side of Faker.
Not satisfied with his many accolades,
Faker was devastated by his loss.
He’ll enter 2018 hungry, with something
to prove once again.
And we’re excited to see where he goes.
[Caster audio]